the world is coming undone imperial
flags ray across the galaxy we have
intercepted a coded Imperial
transmission it indicates that a major
weapons test is imminent the message was
sent by your father we need to know what
it is and how to destroy it this is our
chance to make a real difference if
you're really doing this I want to help
good good I've been recruiting for the
rebellion for any time would you join
our hope five the Empire now
I fear nothing all is as the force will
sing every day they grow stronger what
will you do
when they catch you
you do a Greek you if you continue to
fight
what will you become
are you with me all the way
may the force be with us
you
hey youtubers is charlie so new Star
Wars rogue one footage it's more of like
a rebel spin on the Imperial trailer
that we saw last week so suit breakdown
so some of you probably picked up on the
big changes in this trailer it's really
like the same Darth Vader trailer only
made for an international audiences
really like the Japanese trailer so it
features Donnie Yen GN weighing a little
bit more more dialogue I don't think
we've actually heard GN Wang's character
talk that much but the other big change
is that over like the last big trailer
i'll link it at the end of this just so
you guys can hear the difference is that
in the last trailer the song that they
used was the imperial march so like that
the tone of the trailer was very
different like the Empire is slowly
crushing the galaxy as it rises this
trailer swaps that song for the classic
Star Wars theme so it's a little bit
more hopeful instead of feeling the
crushing weight of the Empire you're
seeing this more from the perspective of
the rebels like we have to rise up more
hopeful tone in the obvious change too
is that it kind of spells the beats of
the story out we hear the Empire has a
new weapon they're getting ready for a
test we want you to check it out like a
that's no moon that's a space station
type moment the message was sent by your
father that's actually whom as
Mickelson's character is in the movie
he's an Oppenheimer type character who's
responsible for the creation of the
Death Star obviously like a lot of
people were responsible for the creation
of the Death Star but he's one of the
people who's responsible for turning it
into a weapon of mass destruction I
wonder whether he was forced to do it by
the Empire or whether they told him he
was creating something different it
sounds like it's the second like he's
this genius who comes up with this
awesome idea in the Empire twists it
into something evil and uses it to build
their death star so in the way Luke
Skywalker has this really weird
relationship with his father darth vader
gin or so has a weird relationship with
her father even though there's not a lot
of parity between that her father's just
another great person who's been twisted
by the Empire and eventually grows to
regret what he's done so let me know in
the comments which trailer do you like
more do you like this story trailer it
really is like a story trailer like it
spills the beats of the story out a
little bit better than the last trail or
do you like the last trailer which
doesn't exactly tell you what's going on
but you kind of get a sense from the
images so you can piece things together
the tone
a little bit darker it's a little more
confusing for people who have never seen
a Star Wars movie before and here like
that's another thing too when we go to
see this in movie theaters it feels like
you won't be able to tell the difference
between seeing this movie and when you
saw one of the classic trilogy movies in
the theater now most of us are probably
too young to have seen the movies in the
theater on first run back in the 70s in
the early 80s but I actually did get to
see the special editions in a movie
theater and there will be some theaters
that continue to rerun the classic
movies in theaters so if you ever have
the opportunity you should definitely
check out one of the original Star Wars
movies in a movie theater just because
you get that classic experience like the
70's style with all the small models
it's always fun to watch the
documentaries about how they made those
movies but of all the Star Wars movies
that are coming the new Star Wars movies
this most feels like one of those
classic Star Wars movies now obviously
episode 7 felt a lot like episode 4 in
terms of the plot going forward that's
going to change you're going to see less
and less familiar things as they
introduce new ideas new characters new
places but rogue one was made like a
classic film in its covering story from
the time of the classic trilogy so if
you're someone who really likes those
classic movies this is definitely your
movie much more so than episode 7 so
it's gonna be a lot of fun and I'm
really excited if you guys haven't heard
it seems like they're casting Han Solo's
wife for the Han Solo spin-off movie if
you guys don't know who she is he has
this wife from a previous life before he
met Leia Organa so there's this really
funny story in the comics where they
kind of spell that out and it's really
awkward where she shows up she's a total
badass and Leia finds out that Han Solo
is married and did not tell her but is
this really awkward situation it's not
as simple as it sounds so if you want to
learn more about that just read the Star
Wars comics that Marvel has been
publishing since they got the rights to
do the Star Wars comics again but a
whole bunch of big news Marvel just
announced that they're doing a Runaways
TV series on hulu I know that sounds
weird but I'll probably do a video
eventually my next video will be the
flash movie because they confirm that
cyborg is going to be a big part of that
so be sure to subscribe to get that
that'll be posting later today so get
high it's going
awesome what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the imperial
version of that trailer and extra hard
core you can click here for the Punisher
season one teaser trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight me me me
me me